herz kreislauf erkrankungen sind die
häufigste todesursache in österreich 42
prozent der bevölkerung sterben
hierzulande haben deshalb gibt es im
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
und sport die initiative gemeinsam für
ein starkes herz
hier wird einerseits das bewusstsein für
die eigene gesundheit geschärft und
andererseits die betriebliche gesundheit
gefördert unser anliegen ist es die
bediensteten auf die unterschiedlichen
vorzeichen von
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen für frauen
und männer hinzuweisen
im zuge dessen werden
informationsveranstaltungen über
stressbewältigung suchtverhalten
gesunden lebensstil und gesunde
ernährung abgehalten informationen über
die raucherentwöhnung werden ebenfalls
individuell angeboten sowie behandlungen
mittels akupunktur körperliche aktivität
gesunde ernährung und regelmäßige
ärztliche kontrollen sind die
wichtigsten maßnahmen um herz kreislauf
erkrankungen vorzubeugen
deshalb werden verschiedene bewegungs
und ernährungsprogramm vorgestellt und
die teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
konnten bei frei wählbaren aktiv gruppen
mitmachen
darüber hinaus werden informationen zur
bestmöglichen umsetzung der
trainingsempfehlungen gegeben
dazu gehört kreislauf von körperkraft
training nordic walking gesundes kochen
und linedance unter professioneller
anleitung wurden pro aktivität acht
durchgänge geplant besonders wird von
den teilnehmenden personen geschätzt
dass die aktivitäten in gruppen
angeboten werden
gemeinsam macht es mehr spaß sich für
ein gesundes herz zu motivieren
obwohl der anderen sehr groß war konnten
nur 110 personen im rahmen des
wissenschaftlichen forschungsprogramms
des allgemeinen krankenhauses wien eine
testung unterzogen werden um nach
projektende feststellen zu können
inwieweit die bewegungs und
ernährungsmesse namen seiner
verbesserten herzgesundheit beigetragen
haben
wir haben die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer der aktivgruppe koch dich fit
begleitet hier wird ihnen gezeigt wie
gesunde ernährung die herzgesundheit
verbessern kann
unter anleitung einer diplomierten
diätologin werden speisen zubereitet und
es wird festgestellt dass schmackhaft
und gesund kein widerspruch ist beim
kraft und kreislauftraining wird nach
dem aufwärmen an den geräten nach
trainingsplan vorgegangen kontrolliertes
einzelturner kraftübungen die
liegestützen kniebeugen
koordinierte gleichgewichtsübungen
bewegung darf auch freude machen
in der line dance gruppe wird durch
gezielte körperliche koordination der
kreislauf in schwung gebracht und das
merken der tanzschritte ist zugleich ein
gedächtnistraining gemeinsam für ein
starkes herz eine initiative von gender
mainstreaming